So, da sind wir am Start. Es dauert noch, mal gucken, es dauert noch eine halbe Stunde
ungefähr, dann geht's los. Wir müssen doch mal kurz schauen, wie wir uns den Stream überhaupt
angucken. Also ich denke mal am besten dürft ihr über VLC sein. Ja, das müsste qualimäßig
ziemlich gut sein. Ich guck mir das gerade mal in der Vorschau an. Ja, das sieht gut
aus. Kann man sich nicht beschweren. Wenn jetzt noch, also mal gucken, wie das ist,
wenn das Sound losgeht. Ob das passt? Ah, das wird schon passen. Das passt schon. Erinnert
mich mal dran, dass ich den Chat ausplanen will und die Musik ausmache, sobald es losgeht.
Wie hast du das mit VLC gemacht? Ähm, Moment, zeige ich dir. Du installierst jetzt Streamlink.
Du installierst dir Streamlink. Das da. Beziehungsweise lädst dir das Binary runter. Und dann startest
du Streamlink. Und Streamlink extrahiert quasi aus Twitch den Stream und öffnet es mit VLC.
Das ist praktisch. Ich will aber keinen Anstift dazu, das zu machen, denn ich gehe mal davon
aus, damit umgeht man auch die Werbung. Und wenn ihr jemanden gern guckt, spricht ja nichts
dagegen, den auch so weit wie es geht zu unterstützen, wenn euch das ganze gefällt. Mich kann man
übrigens nirgendswo unterstützen. Ich hab ja nichts. Doch ihr könnt mir für Paypal
donaten. Aber ich hab ja keinen Sub-Button, keinen Patreon-Account, keinen sonst was.
Ihr könnt höchstens über meine Amazon-Reflinks irgendwas kaufen. Aber ich bin ja da auch überhaupt
nicht scharf drauf. Moin, der Nilsson ist auch am Start. So, was machen wir denn jetzt
noch? Eine halbe Stunde bevor es losgeht. Wir schauen uns Pizze Master Race Memes an.
Was hat das hier Baro da geschickt? Ohje, was ist das? Was ist ein kreativer Titel?
Über Battlefield spekulieren. Achso, ja die Bingo-Karte, die kann ich euch zeigen. Die
zeige ich euch. Ich Restream, also, naja, was heißt Restreamen. Ich greife den von Twitch
ab, also ich kriege von EA keinen Stream oder sowas. Das wär's ja auch noch. Ja, also
ich Restream das. Ne, ne, du musst den Stream nicht selbst aufmachen. Wir gucken uns, wir
gucken uns den an, wir gucken uns den zusammen an hier. Da, da. Wow, es geht schon los. Da
können wir uns mal gucken wie die Lautstärke ist. Wie ist die Lautstärke? Bisschen laut,
oder? Ok, das Geschwätze müssen wir uns noch nicht angucken, oder? Das ist im Endeffekt
ja auch nur Leute, die keinen Plan haben, die Interviewed werden jetzt. Die bzw. genauso
wenig Plan haben wie wir. So, was wollte ich zeigen? Achja, das Bullshit-Bingo-Board. Also
ich hab mir mal was aus den Fingern gesorgt. Ich hab jetzt überlegt, was könnte denn
heute Abend, was könnte dran kommen, ja? Also was, wo ich drauf wetten könnte, dass
das in irgendeiner Form kommt, ist das Erste. YouTuber bzw. irgendein C-Promi, der auf
der Bühne steht und was zu dem Game erzählt und dass er das schon immer gespielt hat,
oder dass er da schon immer ein Fan von ist und absolut begeistert ist und sich jetzt
so wahnsinnig freut, dass er mal mitarbeiten kann an irgendeinem, an irgendeinem, wisst
ihr ja, ne? Dass das kommt, das kommt garantiert, garantiert. Irgendein YouTuber C-Promi wäre
100% sinnloses Mobile-Game, kann ich auch fast wetten, dass da irgendwas kommt. Muss,
ähm, Battle Royale, mich würd's wundern, wenn das nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise
kommt. So, also im Prinzip sind das ja alles Sachen, die bei EA alles nicht sehr unwahrscheinlich
ist, ne? Vor allem das hier Pay2Win als Nicht-Pay2Win getarnt. Die haben ja aus Battlefront 2 und
dem ganzen Zeug und Lootboxen, die haben ja schon ein bisschen draus gelernt, die machen
jetzt Pay2Win, die machen jetzt beziehungsweise oder Lootboxen, allerdings halt, ohne das Lootboxen
zu nennen. Denn mal gucken, was ihnen da einfällt bei der ganzen Sache. Äh, was, es fehlt Immersive
Gameplay? Naja, ich hab hier sowas reingeschrieben wie aneinander rein von Superlative. The most
amazing best ever of all time, haste dich gesehen. So, Free2Play kommt vielleicht auch
irgendwas. Äh, Football, der muss, das ist immer eine EA. Wo du den E3-Stream angucken
kannst. Twitch, EA. Ähm, dass irgendein Auto auf der Bühne, auf die Bühne kommt, wie
letztes Jahr kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen. Indie-Devs, die nicht Indie sind, könnte
ich auch fast wetten, dass da irgendwie sowas kommt. Wisst ihr, so nach dem Motto, wir, ähm,
nehmen uns ein Studio und davon halt nicht alle, sondern nur vier Leute und sagen, das
sind ja, das sind Indie-Devs. Wisst ihr, das ist so, wie wenn man sagen würde, Hearthstone,
Hearthstone wurde von Indie-Devs gemacht, einfach nur weil Blizzard nicht die komplette
Manpower dran gesetzt hat, bloß irgendwie acht Leute oder so. Das machen, das machen
die Leute allgemein relativ gerne. Und das hier, das werden wir auch viel haben bei,
bei EA. Ähm, vor allem, vor allem im Sport-Teil werden wir, werden wir ganz viel haben.
Ähm, aber das machen sie ja generell gerne, so nach dem Motto, wir lieben Indie-Devs
und wir haben, wir haben ja auch ganz viele tolle Förderprogramme und dann guckt man
mal nach, wozu die gehören. Das sind überhaupt keine Indie-Devs. So, äh, Battlefield 5 wird
irgendwas kommen und irgendwas von War Simulator und äh, Authentisch und sonst was erzählen
sie. Wie lange das ganze dauert, weiß ich nicht. Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich geht
er, boah, es gibt ja schon In-Game-Footage. Das kommt garantiert auch. Aber wie gesagt,
es geht noch nicht los. Wir können jetzt einmal gucken, wie so die Lautstärke passt
das so. Lautstärke vom Stream zu Lautstärke von mir, ist das, ist das okay? Football-Resident
und Sleeper. Auf welches Spiel freust du dich am meisten auf der, auf der EA-Play? Sims
5. Madden NFL Overdrive, ist das denn dir allein schon der Name? Dann könnte ich, dann
könnte ich jetzt allein schon hier mal ankreuzen, so. Madden NFL Overdrive Mobile. Ja, was,
ja was denn jetzt? Das ist geil. Es schreiben zwei Leute direkt nebeneinander. Stream etwas
leiser, würde ich sagen. Stream ist ein bisschen leiser. Ja, was? Was denn jetzt? Also, neue
Star Wars-Game weiß man nicht, könnte gut sein. Basketball, wahrscheinlich. Fußball
mit Sicherheit. Cringe, mit, garantiert. Customization, können wir drauf wetten. Irgendein merkwürdiger
Need for Speed Trailer, wo sich die Leute fragen so nach dem Auto, warum muss Need
for Speed so komisch sein? Dann wieder natürlich die üblichen Geschichten, dass man angeblich
das live gespieltes Real In-Game-Footage-Gameplay sieht, wo man sich immer streiten kann, ob
das überhaupt, vor allem ob das real ist und ob das in-game und live ist schon was ganz
was anderes. Das kommt wahrscheinlich auch, dass irgendwie ein Sportler irgendeinen Football
oder einen Golfer oder einen UFC-Typ oder einen, keine Ahnung, irgendeiner, den wir
wahrscheinlich nicht kennen, auf der Bühne stehen wird und erzählt von seinem Leben so
nach dem Motto, wie geil er das findet, quasi, er hat als kleines Kind schon immer noch
von geträumt, mal in FIFA dabei, was, ja, klar halt. Dann gibt es wahrscheinlich irgendwelche
UFC-Golf-Geschichten, ganz, schläfst du ein. Also mit Sims war übrigens nicht ganz gemein
gerade, ne? Natürlich freue ich mich am meisten auf Battlefield V, mal gucken was da, was
da gezeigt wird. Eventuell gibt es ja wieder Sims mit irgendwelchen Tieren dabei, weil
sie sonst nichts zu zeigen haben. Exclusive für irgendwas wird es auch auf jeden Fall
als Exclusive ohne Ende. So, das, da bin ich mal gespannt, dass, also, die zwei Sachen
gehören so irgendwie zusammen. Weil, ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass sie quasi
ein bisschen Battlefront 2 loben, so nach dem Motto, dank eurem grandiosen Feedback konnten
wir unser gutes Spiel noch viel besser machen, so wie ihr es euch schon immer gewünscht
habt und haben jetzt die beste Star Wars Experience aller Zeiten. Na, ihr wisst ja sowas in der
Richtung, kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Und die besten Fans haben wir natürlich auch,
weil sie DLCs wird es geben und schlechte Musik wird es auch jede Menge geben. Und sei
es nur das neue Battlefield-Theme, wenn es wieder so ein komisches Dubstep-Mischmasch
ist. Den Buzzword-Counter, brauchen wir noch den Buzzword-Counter? Ja, wir haben schon
so viele Counters und so viel Zeug. Vielleicht beleben sie Dead Space wieder? Ich finde,
Dead Space kann ruhig Dead Game bleiben. Das erste Dead Space war wirklich ein super Game,
vor allem von der Atmosphäre. Dead Space 2 war doof und Dead Space 3 war angeblich gar
nicht so doof, aber ich bin nicht bis zu dem Teil gekommen, wo es anfängt nicht doof
zu sein. So, 20 Minuten noch. Oh mein Gott, man kriegt Notifications, wenn einer gescord
hat. Madden Mobile. So, ich habe jetzt ein bisschen lauter gemacht. Sagt mir mal, ob
das jetzt besser ist. Du hast so voll wie auf der Gamescom. Die labern allgemein relativ
leise gerade. Das wird später noch lauter werden. Das wird später noch lauter werden,
wenn die auf der Bühne stehen. Wie kann man Twitch über VLC gucken? Du installierst
dir Streamlink und er grabt das dann von Twitch. Allerdings, wenn dir der Streamer gefällt,
guckst trotzdem am besten über die App oder über den Browser. Da profitiert der Streamer
mehr davon. Wenn du sagst, ich scheiße da drauf, dann guckst du über VLC. Ich mach
das eigentlich nur, wenn ich irgendwas aufnehmen will über Streamlink. Ansonsten, du hast
eigentlich auch keinen Chat. Deswegen, für mich gehört Chat. Was ist da los? 12, by
the way. Der war eben mit dem Alter, der darf wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht auf die Bühne
ohne Erlaubnis von Mutter und Vater. Ja, guck das mal an. Alter, der ist 12 oder so. Habt
ihr den Ragequit gesehen? Kennt ihr das Ragequit Video? Dauernd auf, dauernd auf, dauernd
auf 18 Minuten. Kennt ihr das FIFA Ragequit Video? Ups. Nein. Guck mal, ob ich das finde.
Ja. Das ist... Das ist das nicht. Ja, das ist es, guck mal. Ragequit, das ist irgendein
FIFA-Turnier. Das ist irgendein FIFA-Turnier, ne? Und... Ich mach mal an. So. Und es gibt
wohl in FIFA so irgendwie, wie ich das gelesen hab, so die absolute No-Skill-Mechanik, dass
du quasi, wenn du vorne liegst, einfach das Game stallst ohne Ende. Du passt dir einfach
nur noch den Ball hin und her und das Game kann damit nicht umgehen. Das heißt, der,
der jetzt hier führt, der fuckt den halt voll ab, weil er quasi... Ich weiß nicht, ob das
ein Glitch ist, ja. Und das pisst den halt übelst an und gleich kommt der Ragequit.
Mitten im Turnier, mitten im Turnier, ne? Die Runde läuft noch mitten im Turnier. Ragequit,
verpisst euch. Habt keinen Bock mehr. Ich mein, das... Ey, in welchem Turnier siehst du so
was, ja? Und vor allem, warum ist das Ding, die Mechanik in dem Game? The fuck? So. Und
wo wir gerade dabei sind, kennt ihr den... Kennt ihr das StarCraft-Turnier, wo der Typ
mit dem Fuß spielt? Ich mein, wir haben noch 15 Minuten Zeit, wir können uns noch ein bisschen
Zeug angucken. Kennt ihr das StarCraft-Turnier? Das ist auch irgendein Turnier, ja? Der spielt
mit dem Fuß. Das ist so geil. Das ist einfach mal komplett Expanding Brain, ja? Das ist
next level. Absolute next level. Das geht... In Wirklichkeit geht das noch viel länger,
ne? Das geht irgendwie 37 Minuten. Der spielt dann auch irgendwie mit... irgendwie umgedreht
und irgendwie... Ach, ganz... Der macht die ganze Zeit so komisches Zeug und zieht den
halt übelst ab. Kannste Null rotieren lassen? Na klar, siehste doch hier, guck. Null, 3D
Netz kann ich sogar den da machen. Das ist Turmspringer, Null. Oh, das Serious Max, nice,
nice. Der Serious Max hat die Bullshit-Bingo-Karte. Ich poste das nochmal. Die Bullshit-Bingo...
Haben wir eigentlich irgendwelche Mods? Der Sebaro war doch eben da, ne? Haben wir irgendwelche
Mods? Könntest du das hier vom Serious Max mal als Ausrufezeichen Bingo Link oder irgendwie
sowas einrichten? So, wir dürfen den Anfang nicht verpassen. Grills. Wir dürfen den Anfang
nicht verpassen. Wir haben noch 13 Minuten Zeit. Sebaro ist futtern. Keine Mods. Oh, ich ahne
Schlimmes. Da muss ich jetzt glaube ich irgendeinen... Wer macht hier einen guten Eindruck? Der
Serious Max, den hab ich schon öfters gesehen. Der macht einen guten Eindruck. Der wird jetzt
gemoddet. Der wird jetzt gemoddet. Den hab ich schon öfters gesehen hier. Und wenn du
plötzlich was wirst, endmodet. So. Weil ohne Mods geht's hier nicht. So. Aber das war...
Ist da geil, oder? Das ist wirklich Next Level Shit und Hymn, das Starcraft im Fuß spielt.
Magst du mal die Low Latency Option aktivieren? Wo aktiviert man dann die Low Latency Option?
Jetzt kommen sie hier mit Message Delete. Das hast du aber geschickt gemacht. Du hast
ja noch Deutsch geschrieben. Nachricht gelöscht. Ja, ist klar. So einfach könnt ihr mich nicht
debaten. Ich bin Master was Twitch Chat angeht. Ich hab eine eigene Textdatei mit Twitch
Chat, Copypasta und Memes. Die ist mittlerweile, ich guck mal kurz rein, ich zeig die euch
nicht. Weil das ist ja meine Geheimwaffe. Die ist 183 Zeilen lang. Meine Twitch Chat
Copypasta Memes Datei. Das heißt Twitch Chat, da können wir mich nicht verarschen. So, 10
Minuten noch. Sims. Mir fällt mir dazu nicht ein. Dashboard Settings Channel. Nee, ich
kann, wenn ich jetzt Low Latency anmache, dann startet sich das Team wahrscheinlich
neu. Ich guck mal wie viel Latency ich hab. Ich guck mal in meiner Vorschau. So. 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 8, 9, 10. 10 Sekunden damit. Damit kann man doch leben, oder? 9,21.
Das ist zu wenig. Ja Streamsnipe. Achtung, wenn ich gleich gesniped werde.
99,9 Sekunden. Ich glaube mit dem Delay können wir leben. Ich will jetzt nix, ich will jetzt
nix an den Settings rumspielen und dann kackt das Stream ab. Ich mein uns bei so ner, also
wenn es jetzt irgendwie Gameplay wäre oder irgendwie so quasi Chat Plays Overwatch oder
irgendwie sowas, dann wäre die Latenz natürlich wichtig, aber wenn wir uns ne Pressekonferenz
angucken, ob die jetzt 9,9 Sekunden später ist oder nicht, ist egal. Wieso spielen die
im Stehen? Wahrscheinlich können die sich keine Stühle leisten. Und vielleicht ist es nicht
hip genug zu sitzen. Wer ist, kennt man die? Boah. Ich mach die
jetzt mal wieder aus. Ich ahne Schlimmes schon, das wird, das wird
grausam gleich. So wir müssen, genau, unser Bullshit-Pingo ist offen, wir haben schon,
zack wunderbar, alles vorbereitet, wir können direkt loslegen. Falls ich irgendwas vergesse
Leute ne, spammt mich im Chat voll, dass ich dran denke hier Bullshit-Pingo auszufüllen.
Also EA schlachtet ja alles aus, aber Sims ist da schon wirklich ganz oben mit dabei.
Was ist mit Anthem? Ja, ich geh mal davon aus, dass ich mir das
da kommt auch was. EA Leute, interviewen EA Leute, wie toll EA
Produkte sind. Äh, Patrick, was? Was? What? Ich versteh's nicht. Ich bin mal gespannt,
ob sie was zu Battlefield eSport erzählen. Ich hab das absichtlich mal hier rausgelassen,
weil es EA eSport technisch noch nicht so richtig auf die Reihe gekriegt hat, was Battlefield
sowas anbelangt. Sie erzählen das zwar öfters mal, aber sie machen ja nichts wirklich, weil
Incursions, ist Incursions. Battlefield eSport, was ist das ja? Sie haben irgendwie ja vor
ner Weile erzählt, sie haben eine eSport Division oder sowas gegründet. Davon hab ich noch
nix mitgekriegt, was sie tolles macht, die eSport Division. Hallo Troidezer. Also das
können wir safe abhaken heute, das können wir safe abhaken. Kann man die Stream-Quali
ändern? Ja, sollte eigentlich gehen. Das hat er manchmal, dass das bei mir nicht einzustellen
geht. Manchmal geht das dann nach ner Zeit und manchmal geht's auch nicht. Lustigerweise
hatte ich gestern mit exakt den, wirklich exakt den gleichen Settings, hatte ich Optionen.
Das liegt aber wahrscheinlich daran, also gar nicht an mir, sondern einfach wie viele
Leute gerade streamen und wen halt Twitch für wichtig hält, dass man halt Rechenleistung
bei ihnen kriegt. Und ich bin anscheinend wichtig genug und dann, versteh ich ja auch,
ich mein ich bin weder Partner, ich bring Twitch, oder bin noch Apple-Direct, noch Partner
oder sonst was, ich bringe Twitch nichts an Geld, gar nix. Ich koste ja nur was, deswegen
sind sie wahrscheinlich der Meinung, alle anderen sind wichtiger, Optionen zu kriegen.
Aber ist okay, versteh ich. Oh, gleich geht's los. So ungefähr so die Lautstärke denke
ich, mal wird's auch im Stream sein. Geht doch, oder? Typ versteht man doch gut. Oder
soll ich noch nen Ticken lauter machen? Ich kann ja immer noch lauter machen. Soll
es nicht passen. Einen Tick lauter. Wir warten bis es losgeht, dann mach ich lauter. Sobald
es losgeht. Die Musik ist nice. Ich weiß nicht wo ich schau, ob bei Max oder bei P-Suite
was passiert ist. Ich weiß nicht wo ich schaue, aber ich schaue, ob bei Max oder bei P-Suite
Wir hatten keine Mods, wir haben Mods gebraucht
Und er hat im letzten Team schon immer einen guten Eindruck gemacht
Guck mal der Josen ist da
Wie im Tool
Und mehr Mods können nichts schaden
Ich hatte ja bisher glaube ich nur drei
Oder so
Was? Hanzo?
Simple Geometry
Hat er gerade was von Hanzo erzählt?
Hat sich zumindest so angehört
Oder so ähnlich
Hanzo
Ja lass mal inside headen
12 übrigens
Hanzo
Ich hab keine Ahnung wer das ist
Zu leise? Ist okay?
Oder soll ich lauter machen?
Hanzo
Da bin ich gespannt
Wir können eigentlich schon mit Cringe anfangen abzuhaken oder?
Merkt euch mal was wir anhaken mussten
Hanzo
Customization können wir auch schon abhaken
Das sieht schon geil aus
Hanzo
Was sagt mir das Bild jetzt?
Aber definitiv irgendwas Leute ihr habt irgendwas
Ich wusste es, ich wusste es abhaken
Hanzo